let's talk kim k now because she's
revealing a little beauty fact and
fiction and yep that includes some
cosmetic confessions
i'm definitely not against plastic
surgery especially when i'm older and i
have kids
the question what do you have in your
face right now kim's answer a little bit
of botox your lips and your cheeks no
filler no filler never filled either one
ever
yeah that's exactly what you look like a
cartoon yeah look at what you're doing
okay i'll never do this again ever oh
promise never promise promise
yeah despite swearing off botox in 2010
the 41 year old now admits to a few
cosmetic procedures this after an
interviewer for the august issue of
allure doubted the authenticity of the
reality star's face asking those are
your real eyelashes answer yeah followed
by my eyebrows are real
are you sure it doesn't look weird the
mom of four who has her own skin care
line also admits i do my beauty
treatments usually late at night after
everyone's in bed i'm doing laser
treatment i would still do anything to
look and feel youthful if you want to
get plastic surgery for yourself go for
it you're so famous we love you
kim and daughter north sporting faux
nose rings and chains have been in
france after kim made her paris fashion
week runway debut at the balenciaga show
kim hit up the star-studded after
after-party with nicole and keith mary
kate olson naomi campbell and more
[Music]